bien todo esto lo construimos en el
vídeo pasado y ahora me voy a tomar un
punto afuera de este plano para ver cuál
es la distancia de este punto al plano
así que déjenme tomar un punto por aquí
y le voy a poner que tiene como
coordenadas x 0 10 0 iceta 0 muy bien y
ya que tengo este punto aquí entonces me
voy a preguntar cuál es su vector
posición así que déjenme dibujar un
vector por aquí con líneas punteadas y
ya tengo aquí a mi vector que por cierto
tiene como ecuación asociada x 0 x image
0 x jota más 70 x cam perfecto y ahora
mi pregunta es como encuentro la
distancia de este punto a este plano y
me vas a decir cuál distancia porque yo
no puedo tomar la distancia de que acabo
de que acá o de aquí para acá también o
también 4 maestra distancia pero cuando
me refiera la distancia de un punto a un
plano me estoy refiriendo a la distancia
mínima y como encuentro la distancia
mínima de un punto un plano pues
curiosamente es la distancia que es
perpendicular al plano o dicho de otra
manera la distancia normal al plano la
distancia de un punto al plano la mínima
es aquella que es perpendicular
al plano y bueno como la encontramos
para esto lo que voy a hacer es dibujar
un vector que tenga como punto inicial
este punto que tenía que dar plano el
punto x pps tape y como punto final mi
punto afuera del plano el punto x 0 10/0
z cero así que vamos a dibujarlo con
color naranja y éste no círculo naranja
vamos por otro color naranja y este va a
ser mi vector en el que me voy a aplicar
perfecto este es mi vector en el que me
voy a fijar y si te das cuenta es una
diferencia de vectores es la diferencia
del vector que acabamos de definir de
amarillo menos el vector que está de
verde es decir este vector que le voy a
poner a ver qué letra no hemos usado a
efe el vector f quien va a ser bueno
pues es lo mismo que el vector que
acabamos de encontrar de amarillo menos
el vector p 1 entonces que me va a
quedar recuerda que es el mismo vector
que al agregar la p 1 nos va a dar el
vector de amarillo así que vamos a poner
explícitamente quienes f
eso es me sale x 0 - x p
y esto multiplicado por el vector
canónico y es esto que tenemos aquí
después a esto hay que agregarle
1007 esto multiplicado por el vector
canónico jota y después a esto hay que
agregarle 70
zp esto multiplicado por el vector
canónico acá muy bien ya tenemos el
valor de f pero lo que nosotros queremos
no es la longitud de f lo que nosotros
queremos es la longitud que hay de este
punto al plano de manera perpendicular
es esta longitud que estoy pintando de
amarillo y entonces la pregunta es cómo
encontrar esta distancia y para esto lo
que voy a hacer es formarme un triángulo
rectángulo porque recuerda que esta
distancia cumple una peculiaridad muy
importante esta distancia es
perpendicular al plano y por lo tanto si
yo trazo ahora esta línea que estoy
haciendo aquí se forma un triángulo
rectángulo date cuenta que en este
triángulo rectángulo yo tengo que f
la longitud de f es la hipotenusa y
además jon esto sabe la distancia que
por cierto con pura trigonometría básica
puedo encontrar la distancia de este
punto del plano porque recuerda que esta
distancia es perpendicular y bueno para
esto lo primero que voy a hacer es
cambiar de color y bueno es obvio que
está la distancia que voy a pintar de
azul
mucho más pequeña que esta longitud de
la hipotenusa entonces lo que voy a
buscar es esta distancia y también
tenemos lo que si podemos calcular es la
longitud de f entonces déjame poner que
aquí puedo calcular de longitud df que
por cierto es el valor de la hipotenusa
y yo lo que quiero encontrar es esta
distancia de aquí y para esto me voy a
fijar en este ángulo que tengo aquí que
le voy a llamar theta por qué porque
usando trigonometría básica
yo sé que él coseno de teta quien es
bueno pues me fijo ahora en la distancia
y en la longitud de la hipotenusa
podemos encontrar que el coche no
detecta es igual al cateto adyacente a
teta que es la distancia la distancia
que nosotros estamos buscando entre l
pues denuncia por la hipotenusa es la
longitud de f entonces esto entre la
longitud de el vector
efe y bueno aquí despejó a la distancia
entonces no queda que la longitud del
vector
efe por el coseno del ángulo teta es
igual a la distancia vamos a escribirlo
la longitud del vector
efe coseno de teta es igual a la
distancia de color azul a de ahora la
gran pregunta
de este vídeo es como encuentro este
ángulo theta como se hace el ángulo
theta porque es dios el ángulo teta pues
entonces ya encuentro de la distancia y
para esto lo que quiero que veas es que
la distancia es perpendicular al plano
tanto como lo es el vector normal y por
lo tanto el ángulo que se forma entre el
vector normal y el vector
efe es igual a theta porque porque estos
dos ángulos son alternos internos y por
lo tanto son iguales el ángulo que se
forma entre mi vector normal y el vector
efe es el mismo porque tanto el vector
normal como mi distancia son paralelas y
es que esto me va a ayudar bastante yo
puede construir una fórmula para
encontrar esta distancia sin necesidad
de saber este ángulo teta porque fíjate
bien qué va a pasar si yo multiplico y
divido por una misma cantidad pues no
estoy haciendo nada pero ahora voy a
multiplicar y dividir por una cantidad
que me va a servir bastante por la
cantidad que va a ser la longitud de n y
bueno entonces también voy a dividir
entre la longitud de n para que no esté
haciendo nada pero esto me da pie a qué
parte de arriba ya tenga una expresión
que nosotros conocemos nosotros sabemos
aquí es equivalente la longitud de n por
la longitud de f por el consejo del
ángulo que se forma entre ellos dos esto
lo hemos visto bastantes veces como una
fórmula esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme el producto punto entre ene efe
es decir que la distancia ahora ya la
puedo encontrar la siguiente manera
calculo el producto punto entre ene efe
que ojo esto es lo mismo que la longitud
de n por la longitud de s por el co seno
del ángulo que se forma entre ellos dos
ya esto lo voy a dividir entre la
longitud de n aquí está mi expresión
equivalente y aquí está mi fórmula para
encontrar la distancia de un punto a un
plano y bueno todavía esto lo podemos
trabajar bastante y encontrar una
expresión que sea mucho más cómoda de
trabajar aunque realmente lo que voy a
hacer es sustituir lo que sé del vector
n y lo que es el rector efe para poder
encontrar todo en términos de abs y de
por qué quienes ceden n es hay más de j
más seca y quienes efe efe es este de
aquí por lo tanto quienes n punto f
bueno pues vamos a calcularlo
va a quedar a que multiplica a x 0 menos
xp pero esto lo puedo distribuir y me va
a quedar a x 0 menos a xp entonces a x 0
menos a xp y después vamos a hacer lo
mismo con la vez la b va a multiplicar a
estos dos y me queda más bella 0 - b
y vamos a hacer lo mismo con la c la se
me va a quedar más zeta 0 - c
zp ahora hay que agregarle la
multiplicación de éste y esto y me queda
cz 0 - c
zp y bueno a todo esto hay que dividirlo
entre la longitud de n date cuenta que
esta es la expresión para la distancia
entonces todo esto lo vamos a dividir
entre la longitud del vector n pero
tienes la longitud de este vector bueno
pues si te acuerdas era la raíz cuadrada
de cada una de sus componentes elevadas
al cuadrado es decir la definición de
distancia nos decía lo siguiente vamos a
tener la raíz cuadrada de quien me va a
quedar la raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada
déjame poner una mejor raíz cuadrada
me gusta más de cuadrada más ve cuadrada
más se cuadrada
esta es la longitud del vector n y
fíjate que ya estamos encontrando una
expresión equivalente a todo esto que
tenemos aquí que tal vez te sea más
cómoda para trabajar la distancia de un
punto a un plano y bueno esta es la
distancia de este punto que puede estar
afuera o adentro del plano y nuestro
plano y bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer
es juntar todo lo que es positivo y todo
lo que tiene que ver con z 0 y es cero y
x cero me va a quedar a x0 más b 0 más c
z 0 y después no voy a fijar en lo que
tiene signo negativo y que tiene que ver
con xp y me queda menos a xp menos 20 p
menos zp pero lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que tenemos aquí fíjate bien que
teníamos la ecuación de un plano y
decíamos que d era igual a xp más bp más
esta etapa y aquí abajo tenemos lo mismo
solamente que con signo negativo es
decir a xp más 20 p
zp recuerda que en este caso las as
mayúsculas y las minúsculas
lo mismo entonces me queda que menos de
quien es pues menos a xp menos ve tp no
olvides que la mayúscula y la minúscula
valen lo mismo pasaba lo mismo con la b
y pasaba lo mismo con la cem y entonces
menos de me quedaría menos a xp menos 20
p
zp que es justo lo que tenemos aquí esto
es lo mismo que menos d es decir me va a
quedar a x0 más 20 0 más de 70 y estos
tres que tengo aquí es lo mismo que
menos de éste y éste y éste me dan menos
de entonces todo esto menos de que es el
valor que está del otro lado de la
igualdad del plano ya esto lo tengo que
dividir entre quien a pues entre la raíz
cuadrada de a cuadrada más b cuadrada
más e cuadrada que es la longitud del
vector
n la raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada más b
cuadrada más se cuadrada y aquí está lo
hemos logrado esta es una expresión
equivalente y mucho más rápida de
encontrar para sacar la distancia de un
punto a un plan porque si te das cuenta
esta distancia solamente
de que te den los valores del plano y de
que tener el punto que esté o no esté en
el plano fíjate bien vamos a hacer un
ejemplo no voy a tomar el siguiente
plano 1 x menos 2 + 13 está igual a 5 y
me voy a tomar un punto un punto
cualquiera en r3 me voy a tomar el punto
éste que se me ocurre el 2 este 2 3 y no
sé a ver que concuerdo un poquito nos va
a ser 2 y 3 y bueno la última componente
le voy a poner 1 2 3 y 1 para que esto
al final se cancele y me quede algo algo
que no sea tan difícil de calcular bueno
voy a tomar este plano y este punto yo
quiero calcular la distancia de este
punto a este plano pues lo único que hay
que hacer es aplicar esta fórmula que
tengo aquí está muy sencillo es decir
tengo que poner
pero a es el coeficiente que está lado
de la x es decir 11 que multiplica al
valor de x en el punto que nos acaban de
dar es decir 1 x 2 y después a esto le
tengo que agregar en este caso b vale
menos 2 y multiplicarlo y multiplicarlo
por algo y después me voy a tomar
y multiplicarlo por algo y después le
voy a quitar d es decir menos 5 y
entonces me fijo en cero que es el valor
de y en el punto que es 3 y después me
fijo en z 0 que es el valor de z en el
punto que es 1 y recuerda que es menos 5
porque este 5 hay que pasarlo del otro
lado de la ecuación y por otra parte
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de la cuadra
damas b cuadrada más e cuadrada es decir
y todo esto entre la raíz cuadrada de
uno menos dos al cuadrado que es cuatro
y tres al cuadrado que es 914 más 9 y
bueno a quién es esto uno por dos me da
dos menos dos por tres me da menos 63
por una humedad 3 y después menos 5 y me
queda 2 y 3 son 5 5 y 5 se van entonces
sencillamente me quedan menos 6 menos 6
entre la raíz cuadrada de quién de 149
es decir de la raíz cuadrada de 14 y lo
hemos logrado espero que te haya sido
todo esto bastante útil esta es mi
fórmula de la distancia y aplica
en varios ejercicios que veas en un
futuro